well my kind of i would always talk
about generous kind of nothing's gonna
get hands on a plate so you have
literally gotta go out and fight for
everything you can get but it's out
there
me and the grandover trying to fix
occurred around to a possible and it
kept coming down time after time so we
went out into the local source hardware
store and bought all the fixings you
could think of nothing works we
literally had a small garden shed
she went out there and mopped up
anything about something nothing like
what it looks like today but it was
based on the same actions like a wing
action that spreads the load behind
plasterboard and then we came back and
tried it and it worked and that was kind
of the the moment really just a social
problem when I was back at school when
swine flu happened i used to run
everyone's going mad about how to have
the hands clean of them went into the
local announcer and later on yourself a
pound so I bought everything in stock
and went back to school somewhere 23
pounds making a profit end up getting
told off by teachers so stop that lined
up leaving leaving school just 13 and
their mind up start my own children
agency so it's kind of personal agency
that family churches for people and put
them in touch with the clamps
I mean at the terminal program we've
grown so rapidly anything going on
Dragon's Den was massive for us that God
gave us the ability to increase
production every kind of invented people
work since then you need change to the
product and we've kind of come from like
five and restore some 5,000 axis and the
shortstop two years so crazy things
change me find the right staff because
they're obviously it's going business is
your baby so I think so kind of now
trying to find the right staff put in
the right place in the in the company is
my difficult challenge front hand back
trust over something so what's next
group it is we're helping other
inventors that have done the same to us
bring their products to market so we're
doing that through grip it will bring
out some new products ourselves which is
going to the US and Australia physical
fears
[Music]